à partir du moment où il ya un exemple
concret ils valent évidemment très bien
se passer sera pas la comédie pleine de
d'angleterre de lui des bécosses
d'irlande du nord est et du pdk qui
s'abattront sur une femme britannique
eh bien les français vont pouvoir
constater de même que c'est possible et
en plus ça se passe bien et que ça se
passe plus nous contenter dans la prison
de l'union européenne alors que
seulement par ce soir devant les mois et
les années qui viennent
millions de notre action va commencer à
envisager sérieusement la possibilité du
président parce que j'occupe exit aura
été activé en tout cas c'est ce que je
nous souhaite c'est ce que je vous
souhaite
merci pour cette initiative que je
voudrais ordinairement intelligent et
bien
[Applaudissements]
l'émotion parce que vraiment je vous
désespéré qui soit capable un jour de
plus de 18% scène
merci bonsoir
[Applaudissements]